[Music]
in this book which is fasting is a lot
of great advice do you think you say
that gay men are the best employees why
do you say that well there's many many
reasons but you know when you're at work
and everything's going really badly and
everyone's having a big mood swing game
in a great creating like a distraction
you know like like at work what kind of
interaction if things aren't going well
like I get up in the room and I do like
80s aerobics remember like pull downs
like Jane Fonda and that's one reason
wait so things aren't going well at work
the company's going in the tank and you
get up it's not you start you start
doing eighties aerobics yeah everyone's
delighted it you light it like it sort
of diffuses the diffuses a bad situation
okay you know you know who's better
employee than gay men what former child
pageant contestants like if I had a
company I would only employ people that
had been child pageant contestants
they'd have to win they just had to been
in child punch okay you got to explain
that one why what so what skills do they
have see I mean for me I'm very jealous
of those kids in child pageants because
like my childhood in England it was like
rain on the windows I'm looking out
there's nothing to do I would give it
anything to be twirling a glittery baton
or learning learning to tap dance or
like do my hair into like elaborate Fiat
fantasy Acula ringlets yeah yeah but you
and I have the same
I'm very jealous of those little kids
like spray tan bring it on yeah is that
then if translate into being a good
employee so they had a happy childhood
that you will envy
they had discipline learning to
tap-dance they had they learnt to lose
and not lose heart right yeah very
important so my agent is actually saying
to me always saying to me you need to
stop defending child pageants you need
to move away move away from that and
clearly you're not you're just sticking
with this theory thank you no I'm a
contrarian yeah